des gardes opérées dans le cadre de
lakovic 19 pour lever les doutes de
contamination pour cette mission la
protection civile des yvelines travail
avec l'hôpital de versailles une équipe
et postés devant l'établissement pour
réagir au plus vite en cas d'appel
il est 22h40 la première alerte tombe le
binôme d'astreinte est envoyé au
domicile d'une personne présentant des
signes de covile 19
les bénévoles s'équipent en conséquence
pour se protéger on s'équipe et après on
rentre chez la personne du don comme une
combinaison un calot un masque des gants
oui bonjour madame c des secours est-ce
que vous pouvez venir nous ouvrir votre
pavillon on est juste devant sur place
les secouristes font un premier bilan
les informations sont transmises au samu
un processus qui permet d'adapter la
prise en charge de la victime ou et vos
sources de la protection civile des
villes dean n'avait leurs connaissances
c'est pour une transmission de bilan ils
vont faire un premier bilan secouriste
ils vont transmettre au niveau de la
régulation médicale du samu etc la
régulation médicale qui décidera de
l'avenir de la victime soit on la laisse
sur place soit il ya un moyen
spécialisés qui vient ça peut être une
ambulance privée
ça peut être les sapeurs pompiers comme
le smur qui vient médicalisé
l'intervention d'accord d'accord besoin
le médecin du samu a préféré appeler les
pompiers directement pour transporter la
victime à l'hôpital
donc elle sera emporté sur en fonction
de ce que saab ud6 sur l'hôpital du
secteur et enfin de confirmer ou pas la
levée de doute commis l'équipe restera
avec la victime jusqu'à l'arrivée des
pompiers quelques minutes plus tard
après l'intervention l'ensemble du
matériel et désinfecter vous pas les
conflits ont pris le relais oui
exactement du coup nombre à se
déshabiller vous met dans un sac dans
une bande un carton dasri et on va
retourner au seul but une trentaine de
gardes ont été réalisés lors du premier
confinement depuis le 30 octobre une
vingtaine de gardes ont déjà été opérées